someone told me a story once about a
woman she picked the wrong
track can you imagine owning a place
like this as a little island get
away Peter there's someone out in the
ark
hello there's no one there someone told
me a story about a woman who is
restless what do she want this is her
she's the one you been to our
house what is this that's your mug the
place we got engaged we got engaged in
Amsterdam that's not true though this
isn't me I don't know who I am
now no who is she this isn't my
life Eve the
stalking it needs to stop now you're the
one who's been following me I've never
heard of you I'm Peter's
[Music]
wife I'm not letting you do this I'm not
letting you take this from me it's not
your life what is going
[Music]
on